David Boder: [In English] September the 21st, 1946, a displaced persons’ camp for Baltics—Latvians, Lithuanians and Estonians—near, in the environment of Munich, Camp Lohengrinstrasse. The interviewee is Tomas Billi, a Estonian, similar to the woman who, ah, a compatriot of the woman, Mrs. Anna Paul, which we heard before. Only he prefers to speak Russian, and so Russian we speak.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну, господин Билли, скажите нам, как ваше полное имя, сколько вам лет и где вы родились? [Some weak instructions from Boder, most likely about use of microphone.]
Tomas Billi: Мое имя Томас Билый, родился я в городе Виттенберге в Эстонии в 1888 г.
David Boder: Да. Вам, значит, теперь 58 лет.
Tomas Billi: 58 лет.
David Boder: Так. Что вы такой по профессии?
Tomas Billi: Я по профессии текстильный человек.
David Boder: Текстильный работник.
Tomas Billi: Работник.
David Boder: Так. Ну, вы мне расскажите что, а где вы были и что с вами случилось когда Русские вернулись в Эстонию.
Tomas Billi: Я работал в городе Нарву. Город находится прямо у русской границы...
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: . . . в текстильной фабрике, как русские в 40-м году пришли в Эстонию.
Tomas Billi: Они в нашем завод(е) начинались [базирование?]
David Boder: [прерывающий] Начинались [базирование?], да?
Tomas Billi: Да. Как и все другие заводы. А я остался пока там работать при Советской власти.
David Boder: Так. А кому этот завод принадлежал сперва?
Tomas Billi: Это было акционерное общество. Принадлежалo Эстонцам.
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: Там, и...Я был тоже включающий там в этой фабрике. Имел тоже маленькое пакет акцией.
David Boder: Ага.
Tomas Billi: Но, все-таки Большевики оставили меня тоже там работать, потому что у них не было, как сказать...аг...
David Boder: Специалистов.
Tomas Billi: . . . специалистов.
David Boder: Так...И тогда, дальше что случилось?
Tomas Billi: Я работал там почти до ухода, когда они уже, как немцы пришли.
David Boder: Так...Так...Ну, что с вами было при большевиках? Какие перемены в вашей личной жизни произошли? Были ли какие-нибудь перемены?
Tomas Billi: Перемены были большие. Они начали разных людей вывозить из Эстонии. На всякое, в Россию, на каторжные работы.
David Boder: Почему на каторжные работы? [неразборчиво] [надо?] общественная работа, нет?
Tomas Billi: Так, сказали, что в Сибирь посылают [прервано].
David Boder: Ну, ладно. Так?
Tomas Billi: Пришли салоны с селянами всей, целой Эстонии через нашу граничный город, потому что надо было на границе как раз.
David Boder: Ага
Tomas Billi: И в нашем городе тоже начали ночью всегда арестовать людей
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: и возить...
David Boder: в Россию.
Tomas Billi: в Россию, да.
David Boder: А возили их с семьями или одних? Как это было?
Tomas Billi: [Их все?] женщины особы, детей сняли у родителей и мужчины [неразборчиво] в особые вагоны.
David Boder: Mm-mmm. Так
Tomas Billi: Так, и это все случилось всю ночью,
David Boder: Mm-mmm.
Tomas Billi: . . . каждую ночь организовали одну улицу.
Tomas Billi: Ну, тогда мы боялись и все люды начали искать себе другие квартиры, и люди мы имели там несколько квартир. Я, на пример, имел себе 3 квартиры в городе. Одну ночь спал в этой квартире, в другую ночь пошел опять в другую, потому что боялся в своей комнате ночевать.
David Boder: Ага
Tomas Billi: И это, слыхали мы через этих шоферов какую улицу они будут на пример в ночи в захват возьмут.
David Boder: Откуда шоферы узнали?
Tomas Billi: Им дали где им уже, значит, что они должны вечером в 12:00 часов собрать в ту улицу.
David Boder: А шоферы были Эстонцы?
Tomas Billi: Эстонцы были, да.
David Boder: Ага.
Tomas Billi: Так.
David Boder: Ну, и значит и так, что вас [неразборчиво], а у вас была семья.
Tomas Billi: Семья тоже самая.
David Boder: Ну, сколько у вас был человек в семье?
Tomas Billi: 4 человека.
David Boder: Кто? Жена и кто еще?
Tomas Billi: Жена и дочка и зять и, и бабушка еще.
David Boder: Ага.
Tomas Billi: Ну, моего зять все-таки при работе...
David Boder: Взяли?
Tomas Billi: . . . взяли и посылали.
David Boder: И его жену?
Tomas Billi: Жену, жена работала опять в другом месте, жену не захватили в этот раз.
David Boder: Так. И где он теперь ваш зять?
Tomas Billi: Вот, неизвестно теперь.
David Boder: А его жена?
Tomas Billi: Жена тут в Германии уже сейчас. Она работает тут.
David Boder: Так. Ну, теперь расскажите как это было когда Немцы пришли.
Tomas Billi: Немцы пришли тогда, мы все-таки сперва радовались, что у нас спасители идут и вообще. Ну потом они тоже самые поступили как и...и Советы.
David Boder: Так. А скажите, фабрику вашу, которую Советы забрали, отдали обратно на [прервано].
Tomas Billi: Ну, вот. Ничего не отдали.
David Boder: Немцы тоже [оставили?] [прервано]
Tomas Billi: Тоже самое, назначили свои [неразборчиво] команду там и, и, и [взяли?] своей рукой все.
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: Ну, мы должны были там дальше работать.
Tomas Billi: И работали мы пока все там как разбили весь город.
David Boder: Кто это разбил?
Tomas Billi: А, это Советы, с аэропланами.
David Boder: С аэропланами разбили все?
Tomas Billi: Наступление Советов [начал в России?] по тому, должно быть по приказу Немцев уже уйти в [штурм?].
David Boder: И эвакуироваться.
Tomas Billi: Эвакуироваться, да.
David Boder: Хорошо. А здесь, никто не хотел эвакуировать?
Tomas Billi: А ну так, они заставили силу [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Ага.
Tomas Billi: А через эти, а, Эстонской полиции, Немецкой полиции, все до последнего человека должны мы скоро до Нарвы уйти.
David Boder: Tak.
Tomas Billi: Куда, сперва был приказ, куда каждый хочет...
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: . . . идти.
David Boder: А потом?
Tomas Billi: А потом уже мы как раз попали [прервано]
David Boder: Вы ушли ИЗ Нарвы?
Tomas Billi: Из Нарвы, да.
David Boder: Да.
Tomas Billi: Да.
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: Ну, потом уже пришлось мне на полевую работу поступить 70 километров из [Тоилы?]
Tomas Billi: Там опять Немцы имели большие Эстонские умения под своим, аг...
David Boder: Руководством.
Tomas Billi: руководством, да. Ну, они заставили нам там, поставили на полевые работы.
David Boder: Да.
Tomas Billi: Там были всех национальностей, и Русских были и Эстонцев были и военнопленных и мы работали там пока...
David Boder: И были там Евреи?
Tomas Billi: Евреи в этом районе не было. Не былo [даже слыхаты?], а в Нарве были Евреи...
David Boder: [неразборчиво]
Tomas Billi: Они заставили Евреях окопы копать.
David Boder: Так...Так.... А потом что они [с ними сделали?]?
Tomas Billi: Они их [угнали?] перед ним по дороге как их, ну, важнее еще [уехали на ругах?] Евреи. Их раньше угнали по дороге, мы на дорогу встретили, как их угнали все пешком [из Тоилы].
David Boder: Ага. Ну, значит, и вы тогда на земле работали. Как долго это продолжал?
Tomas Billi: Это продолжал из, а, до...долго...Сентября месяца почти.
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: Тогда дали новый приказ, [неразборчиво] этим работам, что мы должны опять в другое место уйти.
Tomas Billi: Там были и Русские люди и их отправили куда-то к немецкому уезду.
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: Нам сказали, что в моей семье, что мы должны ехать в Ревел, наша столица, города. Ну и мы запаковали свои маленькие вещи и уехали в Ревел. Там выдали нам бумагу, чтобы поехать в Германию. [И мы?], нас увезли сюда в Судетскую область опять [неразборчиво]
David Boder: На чем увезли?
Tomas Billi: Мы на пароход [посадили?] в Ревеле.
David Boder: Да, так.
Tomas Billi: А в Судетскую область посылали опять в текстильную фабрику, потому что мы были с текстильными фирмами знакомы.
David Boder: Ага.
Tomas Billi: Да.
David Boder: Сколько у вас человек попал в [прервано].
Tomas Billi: Четыро [заикающийся] на сто.
David Boder: Так. Ну, еще?
Tomas Billi: Ну, мы работали там в Судетской области опять пока уже там начали эвакуировать.
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: Тогда начал [с нуля?] опять сюда к Мюнкену [Произносится по-немецки, но с русским грамматическокм окончанием], и у одного крестьянина назначали работать.
Tomas Billi: [Тоже?] вся семья, и моя дочка и жена, мы работали пока Американцы пришли у одного Немецкого крестьянина.
David Boder: Он [вас заплатил за?] работу?
Tomas Billi: Немножко платил только.
David Boder: И давал вам есть?
Tomas Billi: Кушать тоже было мало, мы получили немецкие карты и немножко добавочное нам все-таки давали.
David Boder: И на немецкие карты вы что, покупали еду?
Tomas Billi: Покупали, да.
David Boder: А откуда деньги были на еду?
Tomas Billi: Ну, столько, он нам все-таки немножко [неразборчиво] [давал?].
David Boder: Так. Так что, вы с картами покупали и он немножко прибавлял.
Tomas Billi: Прибавлял, да.
David Boder: А был он хороший человек?
Tomas Billi: Ну, не так особый. Очень много укорял все-таки.
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: Моя жена должна с утра до вечера все [из скотоводства и голев?] работать и чистить, и дочка опять ручную работу делала и старая бабушка, сорок, а, 74 года, она [опять?] пряла пряжу крестьянину.
Tomas Billi: [неразборчиво]
David Boder: Ну, почему вы не могли уйти от него а пойти в другое место?
Tomas Billi: [По одежду?] некуда был нам уйти.
David Boder: Ага...Так, что вы не могли оставить жену. А что этот крестьянин, он бы на наций?
Tomas Billi: Нет, наций не был.
David Boder: Ага.... Он был молодой человек и у него был много детей зато он был [дома?]. [неразборчиво] [пятеро?] маленьких детей и еще всего 8 человек в семья было.
David Boder: Так, все его [прервано]
Tomas Billi: В доме работа. В доме.
David Boder: Так...Ну, а вы, а, как потом случилось когда немецы, аг, немцы проиграли войну. У вас радио было, вы узнали что происходит?
Tomas Billi: Ничего не было.
David Boder: Ничего не было?
Tomas Billi: Нет.
David Boder: Ну, и как все это случилось когда...и кто, кто вас освободил?
Tomas Billi: Это американцы [вдруг?] приехали уже сюда с автомобилем в деревню...
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: и тогда мы с радостью пришли им на встречу и мы говорили, они что вот [выезд?] значит [Звучит как немецкий “аус.”]. [шамкать], ну, неменцы [поправляет] иностранцы, что теперь не работать больше у немцы, немцы должны вам давать так кушать.
David Boder: Да.
Tomas Billi: Ну, [мы им?] все-таки он не так плохой хозяин был, мы все-таки работали [дальше?].
David Boder: Ага. Ну вы не работали так много?
Tomas Billi: Ну пока [в местном?] мы начали так потребовать все-таки лу(чше), больше пищи
David Boder: Так
Tomas Billi: [Молоко требовали?] одну кучку [тем?] больше и чтобы семья все-таки могла кушать. Ну они нам [могут?] тогда [добавлен?] тоже.
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: Пока был приказ приехать сюда, аг, в лагерь.
David Boder: А приказ был, чтоб вы приехали сюда в лагерь?
Tomas Billi: Да, да.
David Boder: Ну, а что вы делаете тут в лагере?
Tomas Billi: Тут моя семья [и я был здесь?], я буду в Германии, работал, фабрика там заболели совсем [с изнурительной?] болезни.
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: И смотря по болезни я [все дальше?] работал у крестьянина.
David Boder: Так
Tomas Billi: А тут теперь, ну вот, до сих пор так [тяжелую?] работу ничего не делаю, только садоводством вдруг занимается, скомандую.
David Boder: Mm-mmm.
Tomas Billi: И мы имеем тут лагерное поле и [на это?] поле тоже скомандовал тут для лагеря картошку садили. И я всегда был [скомандую?] по этому делу.
David Boder: Ага. [Вы?] начальником скомандовал?
Tomas Billi: Начальником, да.
David Boder: Ну, и что вы думаете? Куда вы пойдете? [неразборчиво] [для вас?] кончится?
Tomas Billi: Ну, это трудно сказать.
David Boder: Что вы хотите делать?
Tomas Billi: Да. Мы все думаем, что если домой не по-, попасть, так придется тут в Германии начать работать.
David Boder: Аг, вы...Почему вы не можете домой попасть?
Tomas Billi: Аг, по...по этой вредной режиме не хочется обратно идти [больше?]. Мы страдали уже два раза вот этими режимами.
David Boder: Не хочется [прервано].
Tomas Billi: Ни...Никак не хочется домой идти...У нас было хорошо своего демократического правления [прервано].
David Boder: Ну вот, демократического режима [уже значит?] не было. Вашей...президент был уже такой диктатор как [Улман?], как Сталин...как...
Tomas Billi: Нет, нет...Нет, у нас было демократическое [прервано]
David Boder: У вас что? Парламент был свой?
Tomas Billi: Парламент свой.
David Boder: Ну, а почему ни коммунистов в [тюрьму?] садили?
Tomas Billi: Ну, если они по, как сказать [уже смерть?] правильно, порядка в Эстонии будет требовать.
David Boder: Ага. Так. Ег, ну, а вы думаете, что вам можно быть остаться в Германии?
Tomas Billi: Ну, если, я думаю, что возможность будет.
David Boder: У вас родственник в Америке нет?
Tomas Billi: Нет.
David Boder: И в Южней Америке?
Tomas Billi: Тоже нет.
David Boder: Ага.
Tomas Billi: [Записали?], что [в Америку?] ехать [так как?] я уже старый и думают, что на тяжелую работу [прервано]
David Boder: Сколько вам лет, Мистер Томас?
Tomas Billi: Аг...
David Boder: [Все понят?]
Tomas Billi: Аг, 58 [прервано]
David Boder: Ну, да, вы мне сказали, что родились в 1888 году. Ну, вы не такой старый если вы отдохнете немножко с [неразборчиво] [поправитесь?].
Tomas Billi: Я понимаю хорошо земледельческое дело
David Boder: Ага.
Tomas Billi: Я [малая лета?] все служило тогдашними изменениями и учился по полеводству.
David Boder: Mm-mmm.
Tomas Billi: И мне все интересует все полеводство.
David Boder: Ага.
Tomas Billi: [Поучу себе?] все-таки где-нибудь кусок земли так [стать?]
David Boder: Mm-mmm.
Tomas Billi: И там что-нибудь еще завести скотоводство и свиноводство или куроводство, я все это понимаю.
David Boder: Так.
Tomas Billi: И свои лет я бы жил до конца.
David Boder: Да.
Tomas Billi: Ну вот, эти, [неразборчиво].
David Boder: Да. [Дал?] что-нибудь [подняться уже?] выработать, [и даже дать?] людам пропадать.
Tomas Billi: Да, это верно.
David Boder: Ну, вот. Спасибо господин Билли. Я думаю, что это было очень важный и очень интересно, что вы мне рассказали.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes a short interview with Tomas Billi...at forty minutes of the spool. He is an Estonian, fifty-eight years old and is now in the displaced center at Lohengrin...Lohengrinstrasse near, or in Munich. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.